D
THEN UTTERLY FAILED TO KEEP THAT
PROMISE.
WELL, TONIGHT, I ALWAYS SAY LET
NOT YOUR HEART BE TROUBLED, MY
HEART IS TROUBLED.
OUR FELLOW AMERICANS ARE IN DEEP
TROUBLE TONIGHT, BEHIND ENEMY
LINES, OUR FRIENDS, OUR ALLIES
ARE IN DEEP TROUBLE BEHIND ENEMY
LINES.
YOU KNOW, LEAVE NO MAN OR WOMAN
BEHIND?
WELL, GREAT BRITAIN AND FRANCE,
TO THEIR CREDIT, THEY SENT IN
TROOPS TO KABUL TO ESCORT
CITIZENS FROM KABUL,
SUCCESSFULLY, TO THE AIRPORT.
WHY HAVEN'T WE?
WE HAVE THE BEST MILITARY
FIGHTING FORCE ON THE FACE OF
THE EARTH.
YEAH, AMERICANS NOW CAN'T GET TO
THE AIRPORT, HELD HOSTAGE, AND
THEY ARE BEHIND ENEMY LINES
DAY 6.
JOINING US NOW WITH MORE, FORMER
SECRETARY OF STATE MIKE POMPEO.
I KNOW YOU HAVE PLENTY OF
CONTACTS IN THE REGION.
WITHOUT ASKING SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS, WHICH I WILL GET TO
COME I WANT YOU TO GIVE YOUR
BEST ASSESSMENT OF THE SITUATION
ON THE GROUND AND WHAT POTENTIAL
OPTIONS YOU MIGHT SEE TO GET OUR
FELLOW AMERICANS AND OUR ALLIES
OUT.
>> WELL, SEAN, YOU PRETTY MUCH
CATALOGUED THE CHAOS AND THE
TRAGEDY OF THESE PAST SIX DAYS.
WE NOW HAVE AMERICANS TRAPPED
BEHIND ENEMY LINES.
TODAY, WHAT PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID
FRANKLY MADE IT WORSE.
I DID NOT HEAR A SINGLE THING
FROM HIM TODAY THAT WOULD HAVE
GIVEN COMFORT TO THOSE FAMILIES.
THERE IS STILL NO PLAN TO GET
THESE AMERICANS BACK FEARED I
DID NOT HEAR A SINGLE THING THAT
WOULD GIVE COMFORT TO THE ALLIEU
SPOKE ABOUT.
I HAVE HEARD FROM PEOPLE IN THE
REGION, THEY ARE FRIGHTENED BY
THE AMERICAN COLLAPSE, THE
AMERICAN COLLAPSE OF TEMERITY
AND STRENGTH AND POWER THAT WE
DEMONSTRATED FOR FOUR YEARS THAT
HAD FRANKLY KEPT THE TALIBAN AT
BAY AND PREVENT IT PRECISELY
WHAT YOU ARE SEEING HAPPEN
TODAY, AND I DID NOT HEAR A
SINGLE THING THAT WOULD FRIGHTEN
A SINGLE TALIBAN, THINKS THERE
IS ANY RISK THIS ADMINISTRATION
WILL IMPOSE ANY COST ON THEM FOR
THEIR ACTIVITIES, FOR WHAT THEY
ARE DOING TO AMERICANS TODAY,
HOLDING THEM HOSTAGE, NOT
PERMITTING THEM TO GET INTO THE
AIRPORT AND KABUL SO WE CAN GET
THEM HOME TO THEIR FAMILIES.
THIS IS A DEBACLE OF SIGNIFICANT
PROPORTIONS.
WE HAVE NOT SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THIS, THE UNITED STATES, IN AN
AWFULLY LONG TIME.
AMERICA HAS THE TOOLS TO FIX
THIS.
ALARM MILITARY COULD CERTAINLY
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO GET THESE
FOLKS BACK AND TO DESTROY
SOME OF THESE MILLIONS OF DOLLAS
IN EQUIPMENT THAT WE LEFT BEHINE
AMERICAN RESOLVE AND LEADERSHIP,
AND PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS REFUSED
TO SHOW THIS FOR THE ENTIRE
TIME.
>> Sean: THIS IS ALL
PREVENTABLE.
THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE WAS
WARNED, THEY WERE WARNED BY
THEIR OWN PEOPLE, THEY WERE
WARNED WEEKS AGO THIS WAS
INEVITABLE.
I'M TOLD, FOR EXAMPLE, THE CIA
PULLED THEIR PEOPLE OUT OVER SIX
WEEKS AGO.
THEY ALL SAW IT COMING.
HERE'S MY QUESTION, NOW.
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN
TRYING TO PLACE BLAME ON BOTH
YOU AND PRESIDENT TRUMP.
I HAPPEN TO KNOW A LITTLE BIT
MORE THAN THE AVERAGE PERSON.
BECAUSE YOUR PLAN WAS BASED,
ONE, ON CONDITIONS ON THE
GROUND, BEFORE ANYTHING ELSE,
AND ALSO, CONFIRMED BY THE
PRESIDENT AND MARK MEADOWS, YOU
WERE RIGHT UP TO YOUR EYEBALLS
AS PART OF THESE NEGOTIATIONS
BEFORE ANY NEGOTIATIONS TAKE
PLACE, TO THE EXTENT THAT
YOU ARE ABLE TO SHARE, MY
UNDERSTANDING IS, DONALD TRUMP,
ON THE PHONE, WITH THE TALIBAN
LEADER, WAS CLEAR AND
UNAMBIGUOUS.
IF YOU DON'T -- IF WE HAVE A
DEAL AND YOU VIOLATE ANY
ASPECT OF THAT DEAL, LET ME TELL
YOU, THE MIGHT OF THE
UNITED STATES MILITARY WILL BE
BROUGHT TO BEAR IN WAYS THAT THE
WORLD HAS NEVER SEEN BEFORE.
SOMETHING TO THAT EFFECT.
IS THAT TRUE, SIR?
>> SEAN, THAT IS ABSOLUTELY
TRUE.
I WAS ON THAT PHONE CALL WHEN HE
SPOKE WITH MULLAH BARADA, HE
TOLD HIM VERY PLAINLY, HE SET
DOWN A SET OF EXPECTATION AND
HAVE EVERY EXPECTATION YOU WILL
COMPLY WITH THOSE CONDITIONS.
IF YOU DO NOT COMPLY WITH THOSE
CONDITIONS, WE WILL REIGN
AMERICAN POWER ON TOP OF YOU.
SEAN, FROM TIME TO TIME, THEY
PUSHED A LITTLE TOO FAR TO A
CHECKPOINT OR SOMETHING IT WAS
INCONSISTENT WITH OUR
UNDERSTANDING AND WE CRUSH THEM,
WE HAD A DETERRENCE MODEL THAT
THAT AMERICA IS STRONG, YOU ARE
WEAK, YOU ARE GOING TO DO THE
THINGS WE WANT YOU TO DO, AND
UNTIL YOU DO, WE ARE NOT GOING
TO COMPLY WITH THE PROMISES WE
MADE.
LOOK, SEAN, AS MUCH AS WE WANTED
TO GET EVERYBODY OUT, WE DID NOT
GET TO THE POINT WHERE THE
CONDITIONS WERE RIGHT TO DO
EXACTLY THAT.
WE WENT FROM 16000 TO 2500, AND
WE MAINTAINED THE ORDER THAT HAD
BEEN IN AFGHANISTAN.
WE WERE SUCCESSFUL IN DOING
THAT.
NOW THEY HAVE TWICE AS MANY COME
ALMOST THREE TIMES AS MANY
AMERICAN MILITARY IN THERE AND
IT IS CHAOS.
THIS IS BECAUSE OF FAILED
LEADERSHIP.
THIS IS BECAUSE THE TALIBAN
THINK THEY FACE NO RISK FROM
THIS PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> Sean: THAT THREAT WAS SO
REAL THAT FOR OVER A YEAR, NOT A
SINGLE AMERICAN WAS KILLED IN
AFGHANISTAN, AND THE TALIBAN
UNDERSTOOD WHAT THE CONSEQUENCES
WOULD BE.
MY QUESTION IS, WE WATCHED 10%
OF THE COUNTRY GET TAKEN OVER BY
THE TALIBAN, 20%, 30%, 40%.
FIVE WEEKS AGO, THE
STATE DEPARTMENT SAID THAT KABUL
WILL BE OVERTHROWN.
WHERE IS THE SENSE OF URGENCY,
AT THAT MOMENT, TO IMMEDIATELY
IDENTIFY EVERY AMERICAN, WHERE
THEY ARE, AND EXTRACT EVERY
AMERICAN, THE LOGISTICS TO GET
IT DONE AS EXPEDITIOUSLY AS
POSSIBLE, WHY DID THAT NOT
HAPPEN, MR. SECRETARY?
>> SEAN, IT'S PRETTY
INCOMPREHENSIBLE TO ME.
I CAN'T EXPLAIN THE ABSENCE OF
PLANNING.
AT FIRST THEY SAID THEY PLANNED,
THEN THEY SAID THEY COULDN'T
HAVE PLANNED -- I CAN'T EXPLAIN,
WHERE WHEN THEY SAW THIS, THEY
DIDN'T DO THE RIGHT THING FOR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I CAN ASSURE YOU THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND I WOULD HAVE
DONE THAT.
EVERY TIME THE TALIBAN PUSHED,
WE PUSHED RIGHT BACK.
WE HAD A DETERRENCE MODEL IN
PLACE, WHEN THE TALIBAN PUSHED
YEAR, 10%, 20%, WE WITHDREW, WE
WITHDREW THE SUPPORT THAT WAS
NEEDED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE COULD GET AMERICANS OUT FROM
BEHIND WHAT WAS TO BECOME ENEMY
LINES, TO MAKE SURE WE COULD
SUPPORT OUR ALLIES, THE PROMISES
THAT WE HAD MADE TO THEM, ALL OF
THESE THINGS, THE THINGS THE
WHOLE WORLD IS SEEING RIGHT NOW,
AMERICAN LEADERSHIP CRUMBLE IN
THE FACE OF THIS TALIBAN MIGHT.
THIS HAS GOT RAMIFICATIONS THAT
WILL LAST AN AWFULLY LONG TIME,
SEAN.
I HOPE THIS PRESIDENT IS
DETERMINED ENOUGH TO BEGIN TO
TAKE BACK THE CAPACITY TO EXERT
AMERICAN INFLUENCE IN THIS
REGION AND DEAL WITH THE TALIBAN